excavando entre los escombros los
equipos de rescate de la ciudad de
bordean acá buscan desesperadamente a
los supervivientes mientras los
residentes observan lo que una vez
fueron sus hogares badín se cree berlín
es uno de ellos está esperando a ver si
el refugio del sótano de su edificio
resistió adentro están su madre su
hermano y sus suegros acababa de huir
cuando lo que se cree que fueron bombas
rusas cayeron sobre su edificio de
apartamentos
fuimos milagrosamente afortunados los
bombardeos eran cada vez más frecuentes
no podíamos aguantar más así que me
alejé con mi mujer y mi hijo lo máximo
posible de la calle principal salimos
aproximadamente las 7 30 de la mañana y
a eso de las 750 estaba volviendo al
refugio de los edificios cuando llegó el
avión y lanzó una bomba ya se han sacado
decenas de cuerpos de entre los
escombros se cree que cientos de
personas siguen atrapadas
los supervivientes comenzaron a
inspeccionar lo que queda de sus
posiciones
aquí es donde dormía mi sobrina esto es
lo que queda ha muerto tanta gente
tantos niños es diferente cuando lo ves
en la televisión aquí hay tantos cuerpos
gente que ya no está viva nadie puede
traerlos de vuelta
además de los bombardeos rusos también
hubo francotiradores
el alcalde devoró dianca situada a 70
kilómetros del noroeste de kiev dijo que
mientras la ciudad estuvo bajo ocupación
rusa los soldados asesinaron a los
civiles al azar
en cuanto llegaron los rusos empezaron
los disparos contra los civiles veían
una ventana abierta y disparaban los
fiscales de crímenes de guerra están
sobre el terreno tratando de reconstruir
lo que ocurrió en lo que antes era una
activa ciudad de 12.000 habitantes